the eager to create new things not like
a painter
okay that's for me painting it's you
know designing
new things it has to be innovative
some new idea in terms of the concept in
terms of
how you know you work on it different
angles aspect of the same things
if it's not something new i wouldn't
touch it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
we're back to talking about autonomous
vehicles but with a different lens
and we're going to talk about tactile in
fact we're going to be talking with
bosmiz
the founder and cto of tactile mobility
formerly
mobiwise he is a veteran technologist
and entrepreneur with over two decades
of experience in signal processing
algorithms research and systems design
in the automotive and networking
industries
prior to founding tactile mobility buzz
was system design group manager for
zoron microelectronics acquired by csr
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
today thank you
feeling great uh sun is shining
everything is nice the office is working
so happy to speak are you in the tactile
mobility office
yes just hold on a second
let me show you around please yeah a
tour
this is like a show too okay so
hopefully office it looks uh
very promising so yeah wonderful
boss before we get to talk about
autonomous vehicles and this
extra layer that you know we thought we
tried to pre
a little bit before which is not
necessarily in the mainstream but it is
a very significant part of of the
autonomous vehicle world
tell me a little bit about yourself and
how you know how your journey led you
to being the the cto of tactile mobility
and and getting into this autonomous
vehicle space right
so since childhood i think um
i love technology okay i started with
the computer science or
programming let's call it with the first
personal computers ever and then
but also worked on how hard was side
architecture systems so
so since childhood i'm looking at
the almost every aspect of
design of the high-tech design
so from that point and on like during
the high school and then even
during the army service and then
afterwards studies etc
so it was always start trying to
initiate
a new ideas most of them are like stupid
you know but
some you know work so
was it primarily curiosity or what what
what why
you know just keep starting new ideas
was it to perhaps start a company or
just to mere curiosity to see how
technology works
what was curiosity and
the eager to create new things like a
painter
okay that's for me painting it's you
know designing
new things it has to be innovative
some new idea in terms of the concept in
terms of
how you know you work on it different
angles aspect of the same things
if it's not something new i wouldn't
touch it
normally
and so you go through your career you're
doing your bachelor's and your master's
i believe in
the technion do you know that autonomous
vehicles is going to be a big part of
your life or
or or you know our vehicles and
automation in general no
the network networking industry
like you know routers
switches algorithms for networking
that was my
you know my study that was
the master degree i i was working on
and later on the first startup i was the
founder of like
co-founding with my colleagues named the
charlottesville networks
so for like six or seven years we were
working on terabit routers like the
biggest ones
uh and i was the in charge of the
hardware designer like
in charge of the asic design board
design system design all the aspects
from these
microcontrollers and the fpgas up to the
big systems you know like
for four thousand kilo four kilowatt
of the power consumption rate mounted so
so the end of the day that was my
passion
and later on uh after some exit
with that when you say that was your
passion and i i have to i have to delay
on that because
when you say that was my passion what
are you referring to really is it the
is it the the extensive hardware the
energy the
how much energy you're consuming the
fact that you're providing network to
people that you're
cutting edge technology which part was
the the passion
i think at that moment i think that
mostly it's the cutting-edge
technology to do something that nobody
did before
okay like creating the
the highest bandwidth of uh routing
devices uh terabit out at that time it
was
something huge uh so that was the
passion i mean to take for example
just the ball design let's talk about
ball design
the first boards that we have designed
uh were like
30 by 40 centimeters 32 layers
it was something extraordinary for the
israel industry i mean were the first
i think to design and build such a
hardware
pcb so you know
getting it through all these obstacles
was
for the passion i think i'm asking about
the transition from networking to
to a different industry no longer you're
you're dealing with now
with the same technology it's still
cutting edge but why do that
right so um
as i mentioned i like to solve puzzles
okay i like to get some challenges and
try
with my tools uh try to solve it
so back at that day like 12 years ago i
think
i was supervising some project
student at the technion where they
tried to solve some problem or
to assist with identifying um
overspeeding of a car approaching a stop
sign for example okay and then
for informing the driver yeah and they
said that this is not interesting
let's try and solve some way more
interesting
in that field uh for example that they
gave them like
how do we save fuel
okay so back at the time the fuel prices
were very
expensive and everybody looked into you
know
reducing fuel consumption and the
emissions of course
so i try to to solve a problem let's
take a vehicle
from point a to point b with minimal
fuel consumption
okay but simple problem now i
i didn't know anything almost about
vehicles
about roads about nothing about maps but
it was very interesting
so while trying to solve it what i
figured it out is that
you don't have any information about the
surface
like there is no decent map for road
grades for example
or curvature etc and you don't have
information about the vehicle what is
the optimal driving configurations
like for example gear position or
engine torque rpm etc that will lead you
at a specific conditions for the minimal
fuel consumption like
engine efficiency profile right so
so then i drilled down and started to
build the building blocks
okay let's first map the road
let's map the road grades once i have
the old grades
then and i can use it um to characterize
the fuel consumption but even the fuel
consumption of the vehicle
wasn't something available on the
stencils in the vehicle
and when you try to use the existing
sensors you know the
inaccuracy there was huge like thirty
percent
and if you want to save five percent of
fuel and you have
error of 30 percent then you are deep
into
the signal-to-noise ratio problem okay
so
tried to solve these building blocks
and it turned out a couple of years
later
that these building blocks were very
very important
okay like people didn't want to say fuel
anymore
but where can you map the world
can you map road grades accurately can
you map the surface
out of the existing sensors in the
vehicle
can you make the performance of the
vehicle okay my specific vehicle very
accurately
and that was some very interesting
building block for the industry
and this is how it started to roll um
so we started as an aftermarket device
company
okay that building small toys you know a
telematics
system to to plug into the canvas
in the car collect some maybe
interesting daytime then deliver it to
the cloud
and so when you're saying aftermarket
device you're referring to this idea
that somebody by
purchases a car and then you have a
third-party tool that they can just
purchase from a gas station or amazon
they can install it in their car
to get some extra layers of information
and security or whatever
exactly and this is how we started
and my you know very decent
and you know modest dream
was to to be able you know to sell
thousands of boxes like this and with
this money
to run a small company like a family
company
the family business and continue from
there
but then it turned out that the
secretary business
is more complicated than i thought of on
one hand
to get a break even and on the other
hand
the information that we've generated
there was too sophisticated for
simple fleet management you know
telematics
operation so the oems the car
manufacturers
were very interested in this technology
so like in 2014 that was the first time
that the scout from ford motors
approached me and asked me if i can help
them
with their mapping surface really yes
and with mapping the vehicle
performance in order to provide
let's say some basic building block
technology
for an adaptive cruise control
application
so it's like a cruise control so a
predictive cost control it's second
adaptive cost control
but the speed will be determined
according to the future
horizon so and like if you are
about to to go into a steep hill or down
the hill or something like this and then
the gear position and the gas the
throttle
will be pre-configured according to the
horizon ahead of you
targeting your saving okay so the first
car
roaming around will map the road grades
the second car that will go there or the
same car the second time
we'll know the horizon ahead of it and
then use that information in order to
stay fueled
so take me a little bit higher and and
paint me a little bit about the
you know the autonomous vehicle
ecosystem we have quite a few
amazing companies working in that field
what what is happening
and and where is tactile mobility within
this ecosystem
right so um from like six or seven years
ago
when we started working with oems
and the fuel saving wasn't something to
write home about
then at that point the industry the
industry
went into this uh area of
autonomous vehicles and
as you look at it you see that most of
the startups of the
innovative companies are within the
sensing
layers of this industry so so try to
sense what there is
in the car the environment of the car in
front of the car etc
on top of that there is a layer for
taking decisions and on top of that the
actuations okay what do we do with this
information
now out of the first layer of the
sensing clay
most of the companies you will see today
are within the visual sensing and when i
say visual it's pixels
the pixel can stand for depth it's
lighter or later it can stands for a
color of course in brightness this is
camera like mobility for example
and it can stands for even a heat okay
like
infrared or something like that even
ultrasonic you can look at that as a
light
pixel generation um but
most of the information you can see
through your eyes okay answer it's like
visual information
it's a triangle but some of the
information
you need some other means of sensing
in order to acquire this uh this
information
okay for example when you try to think
about yourself
driving a car remotely okay like
sitting out of the car and trying to
drive it just with the visual like
camera line there you know
screens around you you you miss the feel
of the car okay
you don't feel the road surface right
you don't feel the car itself and you
don't feel the combination the
interaction
between them now as for the visual
like 40 50 years ago people started
formalizing it like
inventing the pixels as letters in this
language
inventing macro blogs frames etc and on
top of this language you can of course
share information and do a lot of
calculation like machine learning etc
but nobody so far formalized
the other senses okay how does
your car will feel the road surface
okay and when i say fill the road we
need
to have the attributes of the road
surface so for example
the friction coefficient okay what's the
friction coefficient or the grip
level between the surface and my tires
okay
what is the status of my tires now okay
i mean your tires are different than
mine even yours day after that are
different
so the combination of your current tire
and the current situation of the road
that changes dramatically maybe due to
weather conditions
this is something to take a into care so
so tackle mobility by the way buzz
before when you were talking about
uh you're talking about you know driving
the car remotely i was picturing myself
driving the car
on i alone and at the same time i was
picturing myself driving the car
remotely in lake tahoe when it's snowing
and how you know the house because i
because i'm so scared driving there when
it's snowing
that i'm saying like if i don't and so
many senses go into feeling the road
understanding how to turn when to slow
down when to speed up
that you just don't get that simply with
the visuals it's
really a lot of it with a feeling of
where your steering wheel is taking you
you know talking about stories
like uh we are working for the past
four years almost with the bmw uh
about uh you know our technology and
soon like
next month we'll have the first
bmw vehicle rolling out of to production
with tactile inside with our software
inside
that provides this vehicle provides this
vehicle
with the sense of the surface and the
sense of the vehicle
we call that surface dna in vehicle dna
and the combination of the two
gives more ability to the bmw car and by
the way
it will be installed in every bmw
car all the fleet from mini to wall
source
to all the bmw in between wow and the
first one will be next
next month so um i mean
during these four years working with
these guys
uh we were traveling to
uh the north of sweden to a village
named aryaplog
in lapland where you have a lot of
frozen lakes
each oem car manufacturer has its own
frozen lake that
they can conduct a lot of tests in
extreme conditions of like minus 40
degrees
as well as low visibility as well as of
course
low friction coefficient there and
there is a road there that is called
the silverado the silver wagon uh
with the as the german oems call it and
and this road
is the holy grail of the grip detection
why because it gets frozen and
defrost like from one meter to another
okay
so and you don't see it it's like black
eyes it's black ice totally so
so just drive on top of that and
sometimes
it's like you can fly out of the road
because it's frozen
and then few meters afterwards it's not
and it depends if you know a few cars
ahead of you drove though so
hold the tests for tactile mobility like
the high-end test
we were conducting on this silver road
in the north of upland so you know
by the way it's very amazing you know to
see these cars
drifting on top of the frozen legs
from my perspective it was amazing i can
only imagine
you see and then they say that people
who have serves don't have fun
that's a i cannot imagine yeah
thank you for coming it's a
it's been such a i've had such a good
time and i'm
now i'm excited to go and dig deep and
actually learn about
about this extra layer to to to vehicles
and and
maintenance and understanding uh you
know what driving is all about
through through these extra senses i
have a few last questions for you
yeah but thank you for coming here uh
what would be
a one of your favorite subjects in
middle school or high school
i i thought i think it was the
programming
software programming back then you know
like
mp 35 years ago maybe more
it was the language of kobold
and pascal so
that was my favorite subject
wonderful and who would be a role model
of yours or somebody that's
somebody that inspires you in some way i
think i think
i think elon musk uh
and i didn't think about it before like
this but
you know during the past couple of years
you see that this guy with some positive
craziness
drive the entire world crazy if it's
just
you know the the bitcoin or the dodge
coin or
you know going to the moon traveling to
the moon and
of course the tesla car so uh
you see somebody with a vision that
actually turns
the earth a little bit to different
directions so
i can admire such people definitely
and what would be three words that you
would choose to describe yourself
i think modesty
uh honesty and inspiration
that's if i will try to honesty honesty
and inspiration
your fee thank you very very much this
was
a great i i loved it uh amazing
congratulations on on the bmw cars that
are going to roll out next month
i'm sure that after nine years of of
working on tactile mobility it's
quite a quite a big emotional sensation
and so i mean you know i'm getting
excited just hearing about it thank you
for sharing this time with me
and stay safe thank you very very much
for having me in your studio
and today of course
[Music]